hey guys Ryan right here and I'm Dan
said we're gonna watch the campaign
trailer for call of duty advanced
warfare yeah it's gonna be exciting time
for all of us
yeah you can join us in our jigs ki yes
um wait jigs yeah jigs what's Jake have
you ever watched a trailer in Denton
Jake I have multiple time what's a jig
you know a jig like an every Street you
move defeat mmm oh so it's not sexual
reference now man lost interest then all
right so let's fine whip out your dick
it's very common congratulations
a real rejects been loving what I
haven't seen for this one so far it's
really cool like Kevin Spacey's at it in
this it's so cool it's cuz it's like
it's really Kevin Spacey is like hey
it's not some voice cheese to it I'm
like that's [ __ ] Kevin Spacey right
you know honestly I just I just want
this to be Call of Duty House of Cards
edition let's just whatever this
advanced warfare thing just butt cut it
out it was just to house of cards I'm
totally in plumb down for this game I
play a Call of Duty again last week it's
fun it's a fun asking I'm terrible at it
it's a hard game dude it's really bad
everyone is a lot better than that's
what it feels like remember I'm [ __ ]
Mario Carrick the game and is
anticipated to be rated mature but it
could not be
jackoff competition don't play Ram
Lincoln Abraham Lincoln niacin read
Abraham Lincoln's clothes
oh it was the first global terrorist
attack in history they struck nuclear
reactors on five continents
simultaneously she did and in an instant
through our world into chaos with wildly
a military cripples expensive
we turned to a private military company
called Atlas atlas has the single
largest standing military employee oh
sweet
they fought our Wars
they rebuilt our cities oh [ __ ] it the
truth is we often find that we're more
effective than my governments that
higher
not
i sumo is [ __ ] cold oh [ __ ]
we gave them an immense amount of
responsibility and with that an immense
amount of power we are going in an
operation on foreign sovereign soil it
would be an act of war without
congressional approval Atlas is an
internationally registered private
company
we don't need Congress
oh my god this game looks so badass oh
dude
we're all Tory ideas don't determine
who's right power determines who's right
and I have the power so I'm right oh
[ __ ] yeah damn dude that is exciting is
fun I don't care if you oh there's more
I'm just I just saw like every way I'm
gonna die I don't care if you've never
played call of duty before that game
that trailer would have to like just
pump you up in some batshit just the
place yeah Kevin Spacey man it doesn't
matter what medium he's performing it's
just god damn chili this is like one of
the most exciting characters I've ever
looked forward to seeing in a game
before this is a this is the first time
I've been excited for a Call of Duty
campaign cuz usually I don't know about
the rest of you I'm assuming it's kind
of probably 5050 some people by you know
for the whole package
I personally buy it so I can go a
multiplayer game flight ghosts and never
once touched campaign just straight-up
multi player hmm and zombies no not
zombies aliens but yeah as far as this
goes though the graphics look just
absolutely fantastic
the only time graphics can be
distracting is when they obviously look
like like it looks a shit-ton like Kevin
Spacey oh yeah but then there's parts
were like his eyes are not moving I mean
it isn't in developing yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's it's gonna be one hell of a
[ __ ] gameplay experience man I can't
wait to [ __ ] just pick up that
goddamn controller it just looks so
[ __ ] awesome it looks great I don't
know
I think I'll Gamefly it probably not buy
it hmm because I usually just it but I'm
so bad I want to but I like the story
two stories Jory storage looks at acting
that's a badass story it's a very
interesting story because like up until
now it's very much like shooters have
been like oh you know country's at
conflict and this is like a bit Barbie
that decides well we own everything now
[ __ ] you there's the terrorist attack
then the saviors and then the Savior's
become the powerful ones and now then
can everything Pacey Evans face he comes
again this is everything just piling on
top of each other this is gonna be cool
map this is gonna be really actually a
little site about well thanks guys for
recommending that trailer if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects we do a bunch of stuff yeah
and you can subscribe to dance channel
it's a gaming channel I do a bunch of
stuff
yeah yeah Alexander Escobar less yeah
can i have a shout out because sometimes
people [ __ ] another people what's he
talking about I feel like no no me it
doesn't make sense
hey Alexander you're awesome you did it
did it yeah always give backup plan for
a shout-out just use English when ref
enthusiasm I David but I think we do a
sickness like one more for safety
yeah yeah Robin
Tamblyn I knew I subscribed to you for a
while now sweet I love your videos give
me a shout-out please
Robin Tamplin of course you can is your
real name Robin how many Batman jokes
have you gotten oh that's fortunate
yeah people are looking here you suck
Batman's dick who's Romans good okay
maybe maybe probably I think if there
was one gay character that could be a
good comic book actor I think Robin
would be a good gay character I don't
know I think he kind of needs to be like
by himself badass
no I love Robin like Dick Grayson when
he becomes Nightwing yeah like Nightwing
is one of my all-time favorite
characters yeah but if they had to
change it make your gay I'd be like you
know what I'm okay I don't I do not fit
DC is ready for the shitstorm yeah bad
PR event you can just bringing a new
Robin to making gay yeah
I mean it should it shouldn't be an
issue but of course it will be an issue
are you getting Robin get guys are cool
or a girl you could be a female um Robin
is also a girl's name so we jump to a
lot of conclusions what what are you
first off what gender are you what's
your sexual orientation and are you down
to fool around with a rye rye and then
no yeah but come on man be a bonding
experience I don't want
I mean huh
only if it's a girl that's more of your
thing fry lock hey give me a shout out
don't be a dick
is he saying don't be a dick for like
says don't be a dick and give me a
shout-out or is he saying give me a shut
up but don't be a dick during the
shoutout cuz I need to know do we do two
takes one with us not being a dick we're
giving the shout out in a very kind of
positive way and secondly do we then we
give the shout out in a very dick way as
just cover a basis yeah okay okay so
take what let's ooh the nice one first
next one okay frylock
hi you are a good American citizen and
we appreciate all the hard work that you
put in for freedom mm-hmm
pay your taxes you do well you earn have
a good career and I'm proud of you for
all the accomplishments you've had I
hope you get a good degree one day I
don't know how old you are but I'm also
very proud of your community service and
go into that soup kitchen three times a
week three times a week at 6:00 in the
morning before you go to school /
working that is impressive that is
difficult that's discipline right there
discipline well done well done
mm-hmm all right take two take this okay